consider this video an ode to resistance
right this is a celebration of salmon
swimming upstream most of us don't like
resistance we don't like pushback we
don't like obstacles in our way and yet
one of my favorite motivational lines
perfectly when it says airplane takes
off those things this is resistance we
need we need difficult we need strong
Joseph Campbell's monomyth talks about
the hero that answers the call he leaves
the comfortable world answers the call
to adventure but adventure begins with
struggle it begins with difficulty it
begins with that it begins with fear you
feel the fear but you do it anyway you
move against the wind you move against
resistance right you embrace the
pushback right it's not many times
giving punch this is how many time to
get punch and get back up you guys
creatives struggle with this all the
time we long for effortless effort we
want to always be in flow on everything
to always work have to always emerge we
want to wake up and feel inspired we
want to be in the zone all the time and
then they love it not anxiety that fear
the crippling terror of failure terror
of boredom terror of some kind of hurdle
which means my creativity cannot surpass
this and so everything is over I can
never feel good again and sense of
nodding resignation and fire in the
belly that they described and
occasionally
makes us feel like we just can't do it
like we're done like repeat
like we will be undone because what lies
before us is too difficult it's too
overwhelming I just can't deal
we think to ourselves we want to quit
the self-loathing starts to bubble up
from within you know the feeling I'm not
good enough I suck I'm worthless it's
the beginning of despair being weighed
down by too much gravity the weight of
the world upon your shoulders and you
thinking you deserve that this is the
depressive psychosis I would crawl out
of this
[Music]
I would say what is needed is to
to be ripped apart an experience of such
jolting intensity some describe it as an
opiate adjacent to the crack open so the
light can't get in we need to shake the
snowglobe we need to have what
philosophers call knowledge by
acquaintance because what happens is we
were buried by our fear and our
insecurity we can be told of a world in
which things work out we can be told
that we can overcome this we can be told
that we can shake this off eventually
and that life can be sunny that the
storm will pass that this too shall pass
I shall learn from this you can be told
this right we can understand this
cognitively it's called knowledge by
description that won't heal us from our
self what is needed is knowledge by
acquaintance it needs to unfold inside
us and outside us we need to be ripped
apart
we need to submit because we cannot
submit you cannot die and if you cannot
die you cannot be reborn this is
knowledge by link hardly bearable
ecstasy of direct energy exploding on
our nerve endings
[Music]
and when the self falls away to come
like blatant to the world in the grain
of sand I see heaven in a wild flower
hold infinity in the palm of our hand
hold eternity in an apple
the mad to live mad to talk mad to be
saved we become desirous of everything
at the same time we never yawn or say a
commonplace thing burn burn burn like
yellow roman candles exploding like
spiders across the stars so when you
feel the world get you down when the
turbulence is shaking you subtly out of
your comfort zone embrace it smile and
just remember that an airplane takes off
against
[Music]